[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
JONATHAN GRUBER: All
right, let's get started.
We have three weeks
left in the class.
And what we'll be doing
for the next three weeks
is really a series
of applications
of what we've learned so far to
sort of help you understand how
we add some richness
to what we've learned
and sort of take it to some
more real world applications.
So we're going to
start that today
by talking about something we've
really ignored in the course
so far, which is uncertainty
and how uncertainty
affects your decision making.
So what we've done so
far in this class is
we've sort of said,
look, we've assumed
whenever you make
decisions you make them
with full knowledge
and full certainty.
But many, many
decisions in life are
made under conditions
of uncertainty.
So consider your
decision to study
for the final in this class.
In our models so far, you
could optimize your studying
across different
units of the class.
So our model so far,
you'd know on the final
which unit would be represented
with what proportion.
You'd optimize your
studying appropriately.
But of course you
don't know that.
You face uncertainty
about what will
be covered in the final
or upper proportion.
You know the whole
course-- you're
responsible for the whole class.
But obviously you
allocate your time.
You're uncertain
about how to allocate
your time across the different
subjects on the test.
So how do you make
that decision?
We need to bring
our tools to bear
on thinking about these
kinds of decision making
under uncertainty situations.
And this isn't just
about the test.
I decide whether to
bring my umbrella today.
If I bring my umbrella, there's
a chance I'm going to lose it.
But I don't want to get wet.
I have to think about
whether it's going to rain.
It all depends on
how certain I am
it's going to rain, et cetera.
There's decisions about whether
to bet on a sporting event.
That's a decision
of uncertainty.
And that's all the fun
stuff in your life.
When you get to the
anxiety ridden adult life,
you've got things like
whether to buy a seven year
mortgage or a 30 year
mortgage, whether to buy
health insurance, what
school to put your kids in.
All these things involve a
huge amount of uncertainty.
And we have not yet developed
the tools to deal with this.
What's really cool
is that economics
has a very useful tool
to think about exactly
these kinds of situations.
That much like the other tools
we've dealt with this semester,
it's pretty easy once
you understand it.
But it's a huge amount of
power for explaining the world.
And that's the tool of
expected utility theory.
And that's what
we'll focus on today.
That's what we'll learn today,
the tool of expected utility
theory.
Now, I'm going to
ask you a question.
As always, I don't want
you try to outsmart me.
I just want a
quick, gut reaction.
I'm going to offer you a bet.
Not really, but imagine I was.
I'm going to flip a coin.
Heads you get $125.
Tails you give me $100.
So you win $125
versus lose $100.
How many of you take that bet?
So yeah.
You're a slightly more
aggressive class than usual.
About 40% of you taking the bet.
Usually I get more
about 20%, 25%.
OK.
Now-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN GRUBER: No.
It's a one time bet.
So basically-- now how
do we think about this,
whether it's a good idea or not?
Now those who raised your hand
probably quickly did the math
and did in your head what
we call an expected value
calculation.
What's the expected
value of any gamble?
The expected value of any
gamble is the probability
that you win times what you win
plus the probability that you
lose times what you lose.
So you did that
calculation in your head.
You said, as long as he's not
cheating, using a fair coin,
there's a 0.5 times 125
plus 0.5 times minus 100.
And that is an expected
value of $12.50.
So those of you who
raised your hand probably
did that calculation
quickly in your head
and said, yeah, this is a
positive expected value.
This is what we call in
economics a more than fair bet.
More than fair.
A fair bet is one with
an expected value of 0.
So a fair bet is one with
So a bet with a
positive expected value
is more than fair.
And you in your head
said, I did that through.
It's more than fair.
And that's why some of
you raised your hands.
But many of you didn't.
And that doesn't
mean you were wrong.
It just means this is not the
right way to think about it.
The right way to think about
it is that what you care about
is not dollars.
What you care about is utility.
Dollars are meaningless.
What you care about as a
consumer is your utility.
And so we don't want to
think about expected value.
We want to think about
expected utility.
Now, what is expected utility?
It's the same kind of formula
as this but with one change.
Expected utility
is the probability
that you win times your utility
if you win plus the probability
that you lose times your
utility if you lose.
And that is somewhat
different than expected value.
And the reason is
because utility is not
a linear weighting of dollars.
Utility is a concave
weighting of dollars.
As such, because you utility is
a concave weighting of dollars,
it exhibits diminishing
marginal utility.
Diminishing marginal
rate of substitution.
rate of substitution,
as we talked about ad
nauseam in consumer theory.
That means that the next
dollar is worth less to you
than the previous dollar.
The next dollars worth
diminishing utility.
The next slice of pizza
is worth less to you
than the previous
slice of pizza.
Likewise, the next
dollar's worth less to you
than the previous dollar.
As a result, losing
$1 makes you sadder
than winning $1 makes you happy.
There's a nonlinearity
that comes
from diminishing
marginal utility
and diminishing marginal
rate of substitution.
So for example, let's think
about our typical utility
function that we use
previously in consumer theory.
Utility equals the square
root of consumption.
And let's just say you
consume all your income,
as we always did.
We've talked about savings
the last couple of lectures.
Let's put savings aside
again and just assume
people consume all their income.
And so you utility is the
square root of consumption.
And let's say you start your
initial consumption, c0 is 100.
You start with $100
of consumption.
Your c0 is 100.
So your initial
utility u0 is 10.
Now, I give you--
I offer you this bet.
What's the expected
utility of this bet?
Well, the expected
utility of this bet
is the probability you win,
0.5, times utility if you win,
where utility if you win is the
square root of your consumption
if you win.
What is your
consumption if you win?
If you win the bet, what
is your consumption?
Somebody raise your
hand and tell me.
Starting with 100 and
I made this bet with.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: 225.
JONATHAN GRUBER: 225.
You started with
100 and you won 125.
If you lose the bet,
what do you have?
What do you have if
you lose the bet?
0.
OK?
So your expected
utility is 0.5 times
this utility of
what you get if you
win plus 0.5 times
utility what if you lose.
Now if you do that math, you
will find that that is 7.5.
Your expected
utility of this bet
is 7.5, which is less
than your initial utility.
So you should not take the bet,
which is through the mechanism
of psychology why
many of you didn't.
You should not take the bet.
And the reason is because
you are what we call risk--
and humans are what
we call risk averse.
That risk is inherently
negative value to us.
A certain dollar is
worth much more to us
than an uncertain dollar.
Just like $1 today is worth
more than $1 tomorrow,
a certain dollar is worth much
more than an uncertain dollar.
To see why, the best way-- this
intuition here is graphical.
So let's go to figure 20-1
and just sort of slowly
walk through this.
It's a little confusing graph.
On the x-axis is your wealth,
your total consumption or money
you have.
You consume everything you have.
So it's wealth, or
alternatively consumption.
On the y-axis of figure
20-1 is your utility.
It's the graph of how much
you consume against utility.
And as you can see,
this is a concave graph.
It's exhibiting diminishing
marginal utility.
Each dollar of wealth adds
utility but less and less
over time.
Just like a slice of
pizza makes you happier
but less and less over time.
You get that.
So the shape of this curve is
true for any utility function
that features diminishing
marginal utility.
That pretty much
any utility function
we haven't used this semester.
It's not as if we're
trying to trick you.
Has diminishing
marginal utility.
So as a result,
it has this shape.
Now, with the utility
function of this shape,
let's evaluate the
gamble I just gave you.
You start with wealth of 100.
So you see on the x-axis
the 100 point, that
corresponds to utility of 10.
So you can trace up that
100 to utility curve,
and then you go
over to the y-axis.
So that corresponds
to a utility of 10.
Now, think about
what the gamble does.
What the gamble
does is say look.
There's two possible outcomes
with 50% chance each.
One is wealth of 225.
That is the point all
the way to the right.
That leaves utility of 15.
The other's wealth of 0.
That's the point all
the way to the left.
That was utility of 0.
What is the average
of those two?
Well, it's just a
linear combination.
So 50% chance of each.
So the average of those
two is a wealth of 112.5
but an expected utility of 7.5.
So you draw a cord between those
two points, between the 0 point
and point B. You find the
midpoint of that cord.
That's wealth of 112.5.
But then you trace that
over to utility function.
And you see the expected
utility is only 7.5.
And that's because we're not
using a linear combination.
We're using a
nonlinear combination--
a nonlinear concave
combination--
which means that moving
up in terms of wealth
makes you less happy than
moving down in terms of wealth
makes you sad.
And you're really sad at 0.
So going for 100
down to 0 makes you
way sadder than going from 100
up to 225 makes you happier.
And that's all
because diminishing
marginal utility of income.
So it's natural that this gamble
would make you worse off, even
though it's more than
fair, because, yeah, you're
somewhat happier if you win.
If you win, utility
goes up from 10 to 15.
That's great.
But if you lose, utility
goes down from 10 to 0.
That's really bad.
So you don't want to
take this risk, which
is why, although you may
not realize it, many of you
wouldn't want to
take that gamble.
So using this
graphic, let's ask--
are there questions about that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So would
we take the bet
if our gain utility
outweighs our loss utility,
or we would not take the bet
if our utility [INAUDIBLE]..
JONATHAN GRUBER: Well,
you've answered--
it's the same-- those two
questions are the same.
It just depends on
the probabilities.
If the probabilities
are 0.5 each,
then those two
answers-- two questions
are exactly the same
because 0.5 each
would be gain outweighing losses
the same as on net positive.
But if the probabilities
aren't 0.5,
you want to use this equation.
So you basically want to
say is the weighted-- it's
about the weighted
average change in utility,
essentially, where the weights
are these probabilities.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
utility calculation
in actually gambling.
Like can someone
dislike gambling--
JONATHAN GRUBER: Hold on.
I'm going to come to that.
We're going come
back to gambling.
We talk all about the
lottery at the end.
OK.
But do people understand
the basics of this graph?
So using this graph,
tell me the following.
How much-- answer the
following question.
How much-- let's say--
it's a hard question.
See if you can get this.
Let's say that I said,
you know what, class,
I'm going to force you
to take this gamble.
I'm going to come
in here, and I'm
going to tell you
I'm locking the door.
You're not leaving without
taking this gamble unless you
pay me not to force you.
So I'm going to offer
you a more than fair bet.
Would you be willing to pay
me to get out of that bet?
And how much would you
be willing to pay me?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'd be willing to pay
you up to 2 and 1/2 dollars.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Up
to 2 and 1/2 dollars.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN GRUBER:
2 and 1/2 dollars.
I don't understand.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, [INAUDIBLE].
JONATHAN GRUBER:
Well, OK, that's--
AUDIENCE: $100 start, right?
JONATHAN GRUBER:
Yeah. $100 start.
AUDIENCE: $25.
JONATHAN GRUBER: OK.
You're thinking about
that sort of right,
but you're still thinking in
a linear world, not nonlinear
world.
Look at the graph.
OK.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Would it be $43.75?
JONATHAN GRUBER: It
would be exactly $43.75.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Because right
now the bet essentially
gives me the utility of $56.25.
JONATHAN GRUBER: So
your answer in the front
was exactly right
in a linear world.
But in a nonlinear
world, you've got
to account for the curvature.
So the way to think about
it is right now your utility
from that bet, if I
force you to take it,
it leaves you a
utility of $56.25.
You can see that.
Just go backwards from
the 7.5 utility down
to what level of wealth
that's equivalent.
What that means is you would
rather pay me $43.74 than take
that bet.
Think about how crazy
that is for one second.
I'm offering you a bet
that is more than fair,
and you will pay me almost
half of your entire wealth
to avoid taking that bet.
And that's only with our
standard utility function
we always use.
That's risk aversion.
And the reason is
because 0 sucks so badly.
The reason is because
you're so sad going to 0
that you really don't want
to be in that situation.
And so you will
actually pay me $43.75
to avoid a more than fair bet.
That's what's crazy.
So another way to see this--
let me ask you another question.
How large-- let's
offer you the same bet.
Flip a coin.
Tails, you lose 100.
Heads, you win x.
How large would x have to
be for you to take the bet?
Tails, you lose 100.
Heads, you win x.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: $300.
JONATHAN GRUBER: $300.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Because then your
expected utility is 10.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Right.
Exactly.
If it's $300, then I'm
doing the square root
of 400, which is 20, and
the square root of 0.
You average those,
and you're going
to get expected utility of 10.
So for you to take that
bet, I would have to say,
tails, you lose 100,
heads, you win 300.
I need to give you a
monstrously more than fair bet.
And that is due to the
principle of risk aversion.
That basically, because of
diminishing marginal utility--
risk aversion isn't
something made up.
It's not some crazy concept.
It just falls naturally out
of diminishing margin utility
because making you sad, because
losing, because moving down
makes you sadder than
moving up makes you happier.
Any questions about that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I guess
the question is,
doesn't this kind of
more depende on utility?
Because I know that--
JONATHAN GRUBER: OK.
Stop there.
Let's go to the next section.
You guys are way
ahead of me as always.
Let's talk about a
couple extensions.
First extension, change
utility function.
Suppose your utility
function was of the form u
equals 0.1 times c.
Now I've chose this
particular form
because the initial
conditions are the same.
With c0 of 100, u0 is still 10.
So I'm starting from the
same point as I was before.
But now, would you
take the bet, and why?
If that's utility function,
would you take the bet and why?
Just do the math.
Do the math.
What's your expected
utility of that bet?
Your expected utility is 0.5
times your utility of 225.
So it's times 0.1 times 225 plus
0.5 times your utility of 0.
So it's 0.1 times 0.
And if you write that
out and solve it,
you get 11.25, which
is greater than 10.
So you would take the bet.
Any questions about the math?
I just did the expected
utility evaluation.
So you would take the bet.
What's the difference?
Why do you take the bet here?
Yeah.
Let me get-- go ahead.
AUDIENCE: This is a
linear utility function.
So--
JONATHAN GRUBER: If you're
a linear utility function,
what you care about
is expected value.
So you can see that--
do I have that, yeah--
in figure 22.
This is the case we
call risk neutrality.
With the linear
utility function,
you're risk neutral
because your linear utility
function does not have what?
Does not have diminishing
margin utility.
As a result, you just
care about expected value.
There's no difference in
expected value and expected
utility.
Now, the numbers
are a little bit
different because
the functional form,
but it gives the same outcome.
You always take a
more than fair bet
and you reject a
less than fair bet.
So as people move from risk
averse to risk neutral,
or as utility
features less and less
diminishing margin
utility, they'll
be more and more
willing to take gambles.
But it doesn't
have to stop there.
We can go further.
Imagine that I wrote
utility of the form--
utility was of the form
c squared over 1,000.
A weird utility function
but once again created
so that if c0 equals
100, u0 equals 10.
Now let's do the expected
value calculation.
Well, if you take
the gamble, there's
a 0.5 probability that you win.
So then you would have--
utility B would be 225
squared over 1,000 and a 0.5
probability that you lose.
So you just get 0.
And the expected utility
in that case is 25.3.
The expected
utility equals 25.3,
which is way bigger than 10.
So you take this gamble.
Why?
Because now you're risk loving.
Because what does this say
about the diminishing marginal
utility of income?
This actually says you
have increasing margin
utility of consumption.
A utility function like this
says the next slice of pizza
makes you even happier than
the previous slice of pizza.
So go figure 22-3.
This is the risk loving
case, where you actually
have increasing marginal
utility of consumption.
We don't really
talk about this case
because it doesn't make sense.
But just to understand
how this works,
same calculations before
you start at a point like A.
If you win, you go to B.
If you lose, you go to 0.
Well, this shape utility
function, going to B
makes you way happier than
going to 0 makes you sad.
So you love the gamble.
In fact, with this
utility function,
you would take an unfair bet.
So for example, imagine I
change the gamble to one
where it's win 100, lose--
I'm sorry, win 75, lose 100.
So I changed the gamble now.
Win 75, lose 100.
I made an unfair bet.
The expected value was negative.
Well, this person will
still take that bet.
If you do the math, if
they win, 75, they get 175.
Just replace this with 175.
And you do the math.
You're going to find that the
expected utility in that case
is 15.3, which is
greater than 10.
So even an unfair bet--
lose 100, win 75--
will still leave these risk
loving people better off than
if they hadn't taken a bet.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So when we're
doing the losses, when
we set that to 0, we're assuming
that they're starting off
with the amount that they
could possibly lose, correct?
JONATHAN GRUBER: Oh, that's--
OK.
Great.
I'm going to come to that next.
That's in these examples.
But you've called me on
an important assumption
I'm making.
These examples I have.
Let's make sure we understand
risk neutral and risk loving.
People understand that?
So now let's-- now you
actually raised another issue.
Let me ask a new question.
Once again, forget
everything you've learned.
Gut instincts.
Here's the bet I'm offering you.
Flip a coin.
Heads, you win 1,250.
Tails, you lose $10.
Who takes that bet?
Raise your hands if
you take that bet.
OK.
That's backwards.
More of you should take
that bet, not less of you.
And why is that?
It's because of exactly
what you just pointed out.
It's because basically
if you think about that--
think about that bet.
Think about-- let's go back
to our old utility function,
u equals square root of c.
Let's think about that bet.
So what's the expected utility?
It's 0.5 times you win 1,250.
So it's square root of
112.5 plus 0.5 times
you lose 10 square root of 90.
And that expected utility is
10.5, which is greater than 10.
So you should take that bet.
What changed?
You're still risk averse.
The guy who would've paid me
$44 to avoid the other bet
is now happy to take this bet.
Same person.
What changed?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Smaller
portion of [INAUDIBLE]..
JONATHAN GRUBER: Right.
And why does a smaller
portion of the income
change things here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN GRUBER: Exactly.
Because ultimately,
infinitesimally, it's
a linear curve.
So if you go back to Figure 21,
for any given epsilon change
from point A it's linear.
So essentially as gambles get
smaller and smaller relative
to your starting point, you
become more and more risk
neutral.
Because, yeah, you're a
bit sadder than happier
but just a bit.
And remember, it's linear.
You just take-- so if I did
12 and 1/2 cents versus $0.10,
then unless you were
crazy risk averse,
you should take that bet because
essentially you only care--
at that point it's so tiny
relative to your wealth you
might as well use
expected value.
So as gambles become smaller
relative to your income,
the utility function
becomes locally flatter.
Utility function
goes locally flatter.
And as a result, you become
more and more risk neutral.
Question about that?
Last point.
Why did so many of you
still not take that bet?
Well, the answer is that even
the model we've talked so far
misses an important
psychological phenomena.
So now I'm stepping out
of standard microeconomics
into the realm of
behavioral economics.
Unfortunately, due to
time this semester,
I'm not going to
get to my lecture
on behavioral economics.
But you guys want to learn--
I'll talk a little bit about
it in the next few lectures.
I'll sprinkle it in.
But course 1113 is
a fascinating course
we offer here about how
you build psychology
when you think about economics.
And here's one example.
Why is it that even
with this gamble,
even if I'd done the 12
and 1/2, $0.10 gamble,
a bunch of you still
wouldn't have taken it.
Why is that?
That's because humans not only
feature risk aversion, humans
also feature loss
aversion, which
is we have an irrational
behavioral bias
that losing by itself makes
us sad relative to winning.
Taking away something
we have makes us sadder
than getting something new.
So here's a standard
experiment that's run.
They get a bunch of $5 mugs.
Mugs worth about $5.
They take people.
And randomly half of the people
they ask, how much would you
pay for this mug?
And half the people
they give them the mug
and say, how much would
you sell your mug for?
Half people they
say, here's a mug,
how much would you pay for it?
Half the people
say, here's a mug.
It's yours.
But I want to buy it back.
How much would you
sell it to me for?
The average person will pay
$3, but the average person
wants $7 to sell it back.
That makes no sense.
Either way, it's trivial.
It's just a mug.
It's trivial relative
to your wealth.
It's just a mug.
It doesn't really matter.
But once people have
it, they feel like, no,
that's already mine.
I don't want to sell it.
That's loss aversion.
People are biased by
their starting points.
Your very starting point
dictates your willingness
to take a gamble,
which is not true
in a standard economic model.
But it's true in all laboratory
experiments in psychology.
So the reason people don't
like gambles are not only
because they're risk averse.
But even more,
they're loss averse.
So for example, there's
great economic studies
which show that there's a
massive bias against selling
your house for anything under
the price you paid for it.
That people sort of--
they're very sort of
linear, and they're
willing to sell the house above
the price you paid for it.
But there's this huge notch
at the price you paid for it.
They simply don't want to
sell less they paid for it.
And that's just
loss aversion idea.
This comes up in
many other contexts.
So there's two reasons why
people are risk averse,
that people won't take
gambles-- a standard reason
and the sort of extra
psychological bias.
Now, this raises-- this leads
us naturally to the next section
I want to go to,
which is to talk
about applications of this
theory and why it's important.
And the first application I
want to talk about is insurance.
Insurance is big
business in America.
Individuals in America
pay individuals--
forgetting the
government, just people--
spend $1.5 trillion a year
on insurance products.
Almost 10% of GDP.
10% of our entire economy
is people buying insurance.
Health insurance is the
biggest, life insurance,
casualty and property insurance,
auto insurance, et cetera.
Added all up, it's almost a
tenth of our entire economy.
Why?
Because they're risk averse,
and also loss averse.
I'm going to put loss
aversion aside and just use
the standard framework.
That just strengthens
the argument.
But it's because
they're risk averse.
So let's do the math.
Imagine you're a single
25-year-old male.
I'm only being
gender biased here
because there's no
risk of pregnancy.
So you're a single 25-year-old
male in perfect health.
So the only risk you face health
wise is getting hit by a car.
That's basically your risk.
Otherwise, you're basically
not going to go to the doctor.
So essentially, let's say
your income is $40,000.
That's your income.
And let's say that there's
a 1%-- since it's Cambridge,
there's a non-trivial
chance you get hit by a car.
Let's say there's a 1%
chance, probability 0.01,
you'll get hit by
a car every year.
And if you do, you're going to
face $30,000 in medical bills.
So you have a $40,000 income.
There's a 1% chance
you get hit by a car.
And if you do, you'll face
$30,000 in medical bills.
And let's assume for the minute
you'll still get to work.
Your income will
always be there.
You're just going to have to
face a bunch of medical bills.
There's a separate
issue about whether you
might have to miss your job.
That makes this even worse.
But let's ignore that.
You get to go to your job.
You're just going to have to
take a week to get patched up.
And $30,000 is nothing, by
the way, for a hospital bill.
A typical, for example,
heart attack hospital bill
is well over $100,000.
So $30,000 is pretty modest.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't the
person that hit the guy
have to get their insurance
cover the medical bill?
JONATHAN GRUBER: Well, let's
ignore that for a second.
Right now we're talking about
why you want insurance overall.
We'll later get into who--
we can discuss later who
should own that insurance, who
should bear the risk.
Right now it's just simply
why you'd want insurance.
So the expected cost of
getting hit by a car--
the expected value or expected
cost because it's negative--
is minus 300.
So every year you have
a $300 expected cost
of getting hit by a car.
And let's say your
utility function is
u equal square root of c.
And let's assume
there's no savings.
You consume all your income.
How much will this person be
willing to pay for insurance?
Well, we can solve
that by asking
at what insurance price
would they be better off
being insured versus uninsured.
So let's just do the math.
If they're uninsured what's
going to happen to them?
Well, what's their
expected utility?
Well, there's a 0.1 chance
that they are going to get hit.
And so their net income will
drop from 40,000 to 10,000
because they'll have to pay
$30,000 in medical bills.
So 0.1% chance their
net income be $10,000.
And there's a 99% chance
that their net income
will be $40,000.
That's utility
without insurance.
Add that up and you get 199.
So their expected utility
without insurance is 199.
That's their expected
utility with no insurance.
Now let's do their
expected utility
with insurance
but with insurance
with an uncertain price.
Let's call the price x.
What's the utility
with insurance?
Well, with insurance there's a
0.1% chance that they get hit.
0.01, I'm sorry.
It should be an .01.
My bad.
Wow.
I can't believe you
guys missed that.
You guys are a
little tired today.
0.01.
0.01% chance that I get hit.
Now, if I get hit
with insurance,
I don't have to pay
my medical bill.
But I do have to pay
my insurance premium.
So what I have is I
have $40,000 minus x,
which is my insurance premium.
I always have to pay
my insurance premium
every year, no matter what.
If I don't get hit,
then I get my 40,000,
but I also have to pay
my insurance premium.
So basically these
things are the same.
So my expected utility is
square root of $40,000 minus x.
That's my expected utility.
So how do I solve
for the optimal x?
Well, I ask at what
x am I better off
than being uninsured?
So I set this equal to 199.
I ask at what x
would I be better off
than being uninsured?
And if you solve that, you
get that the x star, the point
at which you would rather
be insured than uninsured,
is a premium of $399.
So you will pay--
you would rather have
insurance at a cost of 399
than you would go uninsured.
Clear on that?
You'd rather pay
a premium of 399
than you would go uninsured.
Now think about what that means.
Remember, the expected cost of
this accident was only $300.
That means that you
have a $99 risk premium.
You are willing to pay $99
to avoid bearing this risk.
That is what you're
willing to pay--
before you were willing to
pay me $43.75 to get out
of that gamble.
That was your risk premium.
It's how much you'll pay to
get out of taking a gamble.
Now before I was
offering a gamble.
But here's the thing.
Being uninsured is a gamble.
Being uninsured is
like taking the gamble.
So the example I had before,
I locked you in the room.
And you have to pay me if
you want avoid the bet.
That's insurance.
You are locked in this life.
You're locked into
being in Cambridge.
You're dealing with a 1% risk
getting hit by a car always.
So the question is, how much
will you pay to avoid at least
the financial cost-- forget the
trauma, the financial costs--
of being hit by that car?
And the answer is, you'll pay
$99 above the expected damage
it will do.
And that is why
insurance is big business
because people will pay to avoid
being put in risky situations.
So insurance is a very
profitable exploit.
Now, in fact, of course,
the insurance industry
is like any other industry.
The supply side and
competition, and whether that
will lead to profits
and stuff like that.
Depends on the
whole supply side.
This is just the demand side.
But the point is
that there's going
to be huge demand for
insurance, and people
will be willing to pay much
more than it costs the insurance
companies.
The consumers expect
to pay the $300 a year.
And they're getting almost
$400 a year in premium.
So the insurance company
makes that money.
And basically, that's why
insurance is big business.
Now, here's a couple of things
I'd like you to show yourself
in your copious spare time.
First of all, this
risk premium should be
bigger as the loss gets bigger.
Why?
Because you're moving
away from that linear part
towards the nonlinear part
of the utility function.
Similarly, this
risk premium should
fall as your income is higher.
Why?
Because once again,
that makes you
more towards the linear part.
The bottom line is
the bigger the risk is
relative to your income, the
more risk averse you become.
The more you move from that
linear part of the curve
onto the nonlinear
part of the curve.
So that's the key thing.
What matters is risk
relative to your income.
That's going to determine
your value, your willingness
to pay for insurance.
So for example, let's
think of your decision
to go buy consumer
electronics and the warranty.
And they always
offer you a warranty.
Now, those warranties are
expected value negative.
If you take the
odds of your machine
breaking-- if you go
to buy a new stereo.
As if people buy
stereos anymore.
You're going to
buy a car stereo.
People still buy those.
You're going to
buy a car stereo.
You take the odds of that
breaking times the cost
it would take to fix it.
Those multiplied are less
than what they'll charge you
for the insurance premium.
It's a bad bet but
it's insurance.
And so the question is,
should you take that?
Well, that depends on
how wealthy you are.
I should never take that because
my car radio cost is tiny
relative to my income.
Someone who has low
income might decide
that's a large gamble
relative my income.
I don't want to take that.
So I want to buy the insurance
offered by the manufacturer.
So once again, it's all
about the size of the risk
relative to your income.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What if
I have increased
chance of breaking my phone?
JONATHAN GRUBER: Well,
that's a separate issue.
We'll talk about that later.
That's called moral hazard.
You might-- well,
it's not moral hazard.
What you're saying is
there's heterogeneity.
And you know you're actually--
that for you it is a fair bet
because you're clumsy.
Well, then you should
definitely take it.
This is saying
risk aversion works
in favor of you taking it.
Clumsiness further works
And we'll talk about
that in a lecture or two
when we talk about government
provision of insurance.
So that's sort of the
first application,
which is thinking
about insurance
and why it's such big
business in America.
And it is huge
The second application
is thinking
about our friend the lottery.
Big news lately.
We talked.
There was a couple of
huge lottery payouts.
So let's talk about--
actually, let's do this.
Let's talk about the lottery.
Now, the lottery
is a total rip off.
The expected value of a
lottery purchase is 50%.
So every dollar you spend on
the lottery, over all lottery
options--
for every dollar you spend,
the expected payout is $0.50,
is a much, much
less than fair bet.
And yet lotteries
are wildly popular.
Actually, the beginnings
of this country, the US
were financed by a lottery.
Much of the money they
government raised initially
to set up America
came from a lottery.
And state lotteries are a huge
source of public financing
right now across America.
Now, why do people
play lotteries.
Well, there's
basically four theories
for why people play lotteries.
The first is that
people are risk loving.
In fact, that were wrong,
That's why they play lotteries.
How do we know that
theory is wrong?
theory is its face wrong,
that people are risk loving?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The
demonstration in class.
Lots of didn't
raise their hands.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Well,
that's one way we might know.
But how do we know
more globally?
You guys could just
be a weird bunch.
How do you we know
more globally?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because
of [INAUDIBLE]..
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yeah.
But that's absolutely
right, theoretically.
But that's theoretical.
In the real world, what
piece of evidence can
you immediately point
to that I recently
pointed out that could
show you this is wrong.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: People buy insurance.
JONATHAN GRUBER:
People buy insurance.
If they're risk loving, why
are they buying insurance?
So clearly people
aren't risk loving.
We wouldn't spend 10%
of GDP on insurance.
So that theory is clearly wrong.
OK.
That's theory one.
Now, the second theory is
a somewhat subtler version
of this theory, which
is quite interesting,
which is that people are both
risk averse and risk loving.
So that risk aversion varies.
Risk tolerance, let's
call it, varies.
And then in
particular, people are
risk averse over small
gambles, but risk
loving over big gambles.
So let's look at figure 20-4.
This is an example
of what we call
Friedman-Savage preferences.
You don't need to know that.
But they had this idea that
maybe people are locally
risk averse but
globally risk loving.
Let's see what this--
let me explain this.
This is sort of complicated.
So imagine that I'm
going to offer you
a 50-50 gamble
between w1 and w3.
So a gamble leaves you at w1
and a gamble leaves you at w3
at 50% chance.
Well, if we look at
between w1 and w3,
we're on the concave part
of the utility function.
And as a result, I will
not take that gamble.
That gamble leaves me at point
B, which is below B star.
So basically, I will
not take that gamble.
That leaves me worse off than
just having w1 plus w3 over 2
with certainty.
This is just if you
hold your hand--
if you hold your hands
between w1 and w3,
that's just the
graph we saw before.
You won't take that bet.
But now let's say
once you get above w3,
once you're rich enough,
you're risk loving.
Let's say people are
risk averse at first
but then get risk loving.
So if you started it--
if you said you were starting
at w3 plus w5 over 2,
I'd offer you a gamble
between w3 and w5.
Then you're risk
loving in that range.
And you take it.
So once you get rich enough,
you start to get risk loving.
So I talked about before getting
rich or getting more and more
risk neutral as you get richer.
What if it goes the other way?
What if you actually get risk
loving when you get richer?
Well, then, if you think about
the whole Mega Millions thing,
you could see that over the
whole distribution from w1
to w5, people might
want to take that risk.
That you could actually be
risk loving over these gambles,
over these giant gambles.
And that could explain why
people play Mega Millions.
That over the giant
gambles, they're
risk loving, even if over
more moderate gambles
they're risk averse.
You don't insure yourself
for a billion dollars.
You insure yourself for
a few thousand dollars.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How does the size of
the gamble we're talking about
determine-- we're talking
about small bets that
are more linear, is it based
on what the player puts in
or what they get in return?
JONATHAN GRUBER: Both.
Both.
It's basically about--
it's about expected utility
calculations.
Yes, it's true,
for Mega Millions,
you put in $2 for the chance
of winning $1.6 billion.
But your probability is way,
way lower than 2 in 1.6 billion.
So it's still unfair.
So the Friedman-Savage
hypothesis--
you don't need to know
the name, once again.
This hypothesis is
that what's happening
is that people are first risk
averse, but then risk loving.
Well, how could we test and
actually disprove this theory?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like scratch offs.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yeah.
If this is true, people
would love Mega Millions
but hate $10 scratch offs.
In fact, the vast majority
of lottery playing
is not Mega Millions.
It's $10 scratch off.
Most money spent on lotteries
are $10 and $20 gambles
where you bet $1
to win $10 or $20.
You should be risk averse over
that, or at best risk neutral.
You shouldn't be risk loving
over those tiny gambles.
And yet that's most of
what lottery players do.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't not
really a scratch off be
counted internally as not
getting money instead of losing
money?
JONATHAN GRUBER:
Well, no, but you've
lost the dollar you spent.
And that dollar--
I still offered you a gamble.
Spend $1, win $10, with
a 0.05 probability.
AUDIENCE: I mean, in
the loss averse sense.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Well, we're
not doing loss aversion.
Loss aversion is sort of hard.
You don't have to
think about gambling.
Loss aversion is
more about losing.
But in the regular-- you
can see you shouldn't do
that unless you're risk loving.
But even this theory would say
you're not locally risk loving.
So this theory is
out, which leaves us
with two more theories.
The first theory is that
this is entertainment.
That in people's
utility function
is not just consumption
but the thrill
of finding out if they won.
My wife, against
my better judgment,
went out and bought a
Mega Millions ticket.
And she got utility
out of waiting
for that number to come up.
And it was pretty cheap utility.
Cost her $2.
So in that sense, maybe
you play the lottery a lot
for entertainment.
That's one theory,
unfortunately,
the other theory is ignorance.
That basically, the
saying is the lottery
is a tax on the stupid.
Basically just don't understand
what a bad deal this is.
And the problem is we don't
know which of these theories
is right.
And they have very
different implications
for government policy.
If this theory is right,
if this theory is right,
then the government
should support lotteries,
where essentially the
government is essentially
getting paid for
providing entertainment.
It's what the lotteries
often call the voluntary tax.
That I am basically giving
the government money
that can run our
schools in return
for the government giving me the
entertainment value of seeing
if my scratch off won.
That's great.
That's welfare improving.
Under this theory, we should
be discouraging lotteries.
That all we're doing is taking
a bunch of ignorant people
and getting them to
waste their money.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there
almost a possibility
that there is this concept
of having nothing to lose.
If you're already too
poor to be able to afford
your basic needs,
then you might feel
like, I may as well
try and win the lottery
and then I would be all set.
That is--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN GRUBER:
That's exactly this.
That wouldn't explain why
I'd pay the $20 scratch off.
That's an absolute
reason why I'd
go ahead, even if
I was starving,
and play the Mega Millions.
And that's the Friedman-Savage
hypothesis, absolutely.
But that can't explain why
in fact, in some low income
communities, among
some low income groups,
they'll spend as much
as 20% of their income
every year on the
lottery, a net.
They're losing huge amounts of
money on scratch off tickets.
So the question is, is
that a rational decision
because they find
it entertaining
or an irrational decision
because they just don't
understand what's going on?
And unfortunately, we
don't know the answer.
But we do know it's
very important.
It's important because
there's big bucks
and in many low
income communities
it's a huge source
of expenditure.
So I can't give you
the answer to that.
I can just tell you it's
an important question.
I hope someday
someone to figure out
how to think about
this because it's got
very important implications.
So let me stop there.
That's all I want to
say about uncertainty.
And we'll come back and do
another topic on Wednesday.